as American Psycho Gavin Newsom locked
down his political opponents beaches in
one of the few conservative counties in
California
your humble correspondent broke the law
to lounge in the Sun the lockdown
authoritarians don't have any arguments
anymore to defend through draconian
policies but that isn't the point the
cruelty is the point then Joe Biden
blows it when addressing sexual assault
allegations against him but it won't
matter
feminism dies with a tweet and Hollywood
tries to rewrite the history of one of
the most important women in the history
of the conservative movement I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Dole
show
[Music]
which is it for these lockdowns about
public health or are they about politics
I think I have the answer but I'd be
curious to know what you think in the
comment section I broke the law I'm a
criminal at any moment now the LAPD
could knock down my studio door and drag
me away
gavin newsom state secret police could
pull me away because I violated his
Beach lockdown were and I did it
gleefully I first went to Huntington
Beach which is one of the OC beaches
then when we couldn't get on the beach
there I went down to Newport Beach now
you got to remember gavin newsom he
ordered his lockdown of california then
he said he was going to start opening up
california and then he very specifically
said that he was going to shut down
beaches in Orange County Orange County
one of the few somewhat conservative
counties in a metro area of California
so we first go to Huntington Beach there
was a big protest of this lockdown on
Friday so we thought we'd get on the
beach they have not only the yellow tape
up at all the beach entrances they have
cops patrolling at yellow tape so even
if you wanted to break the rules and go
onto the beach the cops would just grab
you right as you tried to walk on not
just that there were helicopters
patrolling the beach ordering people to
go inside I took this video of one just
on my iPhone
[Music]
[Music]
this is something that was
extraordinarily eerie about not only
what we heard out of that helicopter but
even what we heard from some of the cops
walking around and from some of the
other bullhorns is all of these law
enforcement officers tried to sound so
pleasant oh excuse me
sorry sorry for the inconvenience go
home right now because the state has
ordered law enforcement officers with
guns to kick you off of the beach but
Ray we're really sorry it's for your own
benefit you know so smiley so kind so
nice but the end result is the same the
governor is ordering you imprisoned in
your own homes and if you even try to go
out and take a walk in the sunshine will
bully you out of there and put you back
indoors that was Huntington you couldn't
get on the beach at Huntington wasn't
possible so we drove about ten minutes
down the road down PCH and got to
Newport Beach Newport Beach a little
more a freedom-loving down there there
were people on the beach so we walked
onto the beach and then at a certain
point the lifeguard SUVs rolled up
followed by the cop SUVs rolling up with
the same message ordering people off the
beach now what's so interesting about
this video again I just got it on my
phone is the lifeguards and the cops
they order everyone off the beach and
the people on Newport Beach they just
don't move
alright it goes on there's still some
more you know please leave the beach hey
everybody the governor leaves Abbi and
as they're driving by there's just
people sitting there in their chairs
like oh hey officer are you doing but by
that's the the better attitude toward it
I think Newport was a lot better than
than Huntington in terms of the people
who were going to the beach the cops
patrolled no one really paid attention
some people maybe left a little bit then
the minute the cops are gone the people
just went right on the beach and that
was that the beach closures have nothing
to do with public health this is the key
takeaway that I saw firsthand the beach
closures are purely punitive they are
just meant to punish you they're just
meant to make you feel bad now how do we
know this well for starters there's a
research that just came out of the Queen
Elizabeth Hospital Foundation Trust in
the University of East Anglia in England
which shows that a deficiency of vitamin
D apparently makes the corona virus far
more dangerous compared the average
vitamin D levels of 20 European
countries with kovat 19 mortality rates
found significant relationships between
vitamin D and the number of deaths
caused by this infection so it basically
stands to reason if you go out and get a
little bit of sunshine you're gonna be
healthier than if you stay cramped in
this these dank indoor spaces all the
time obviously if we want to keep our
vitamin D levels up no better place to
do in Southern California than at the
beach they don't care they're ordering
you indoors another reason this is
ridiculous the beaches are huge so one
thing I saw in Huntington Beach is the
huge wide Beach is totally empty the
sidewalks packed full of people if you
want people to social distance how about
you open up the giant open spaces if you
did that people obviously would be far
further apart than they would be
otherwise when I I finally did make it
down to Newport Beach once the cops went
away I just went down with my chairs
hung out there for a few hours we
weren't just six feet apart we were
probably 30 or 40 feet apart at that
point but it doesn't matter Gavin
Newsome that that's not the point
the point is not the social distance
third reason why fresh air is always
good having a little fresh air is good
for the body especially when we're
talking about airborne illnesses I
you can be cramped up cooped up with
people and sharing the same stagnant air
or you can be out in the fresh air but
the the key giveaway that this is just
political punishment is that Newsom
singled out his political opponents
County OSI the volume of density the
volume of people and concentrated space
particularly in a few cities few coastal
cities off and around the Orange County
area
those were the point of particular
concern so today we want to make some
clarification so we're gonna do a hard
close in that part of the state just in
the Orange County area yeah just in that
area Orange County area you know just in
that area that voted against me when I
ran for governor just just in that area
you jerks you monsters yeah the other
areas there okay but just in that one
area full of my political opponents
pathetic stuff what did I do at the
beach what did I do when I was violating
the law I ate a taco and I read the
Aeneid and I caught some sunshine that's
it that's but that's pretty much all
anybody was doing reading a book kind of
listening to music drinking a little bit
that's it okay everyone was very far
apart all that this is about is just
politicians covering their derrieres it
occurred to me while sitting on the
beach this is going to get a lot worse
before it gets any better not because of
the virus but because of the politics of
it why there's increasing evidence that
the lockdowns didn't save a single life
not just that they were ineffective but
that they didn't save a single life the
two the only two things the lockdowns
can accomplish are flatten the curve so
as not to overwhelm the hospital system
and flatten the curve until we can get a
point but we can get to a point where we
have a vaccine and that will save a lot
of lives however we didn't come close to
overwhelming the hospital system even in
the places that were at the center of
the epidemic so that bet argument off
the table we're not close to a vaccine
and there's increasing evidence that the
virus is spreading much
faster there were many many more people
infected than we thought that there were
and so it it seems very unlikely if not
impossible that we're gonna get a
vaccine before this virus spreads
throughout a huge portion of the
population so there's no evidence that
the lockdowns accomplished much of
anything at all there is increasing
evidence that the governors and the
mayors need to convince people that the
lockdowns were necessary you're even
seeing this at the federal government
federal state and local and so we need
to have these or politicians think we
need to have these punitive measures
like beach closures to play on cognitive
dissonance that's that's the principle
that's a player what does cognitive
dissonance so when you're seeing a
disagreement between your behavior and
what you see intellectually to be true
there's more to it than that but that's
a simple description of it what people
are seeing what people are reasoning
through intellectually is the lockdowns
were an overreach they increasingly do
not seem to be necessary they
increasingly seem to be making things
worse right because the economy has
completely crashed people's livelihoods
are being ruined suicide rates we're
gonna go up drug overdose rates are
gonna go up people are looking at it
saying wow this is a bad policy and even
if it made sense five weeks ago it
certainly doesn't make sense now right
and yet the politicians have doubled
down on it to make it seem like it was
necessary and so they're they're forcing
people back indoors they're forcing
people away from the beach they're not
letting anybody return to anything even
slightly resembling a normal life Gavin
Newsom says it's not going to just be
weeks it's gonna be months before we
reopen churches we're gonna all the
things that really matter to you we're
not going to reopen because if we're all
cooped up inside if we're not gonna walk
on the beach even though it's perfectly
fine to walk on the beach following all
the rules you can still go to the beach
if we stay cooped up inside we're gonna
feel like this is a super serious thing
our behavior is going to be telling us
that this is the end of the world and we
have to stay indoors and so it will be
easier to convince ourselves that the
politicians were right in the first
place
but they're not this is a complete
political rear-end covering right now
and all of the incentives are going to
in place for politicians to make this
worse you know in a very simple shallow
level it people think that politicians
want to make this easier for us they
wanted us to help go back to work they
want us to be able to go outside and
enjoy ourselves enjoy the sunshine no it
actually will be better for the alarmist
politicians if this feels tougher on us
because it makes it look like they were
right in the first place we will get two
more on this principle and we'll get to
the Biden interview in just a moment
first though I've got to thank our
friends ever equipped I have to thank
all of our friends our sponsors who've
stuck with us you know pretty crazy days
we're in right now tough times
economically we really appreciate our
sponsors who were sticking with us and
allowing us to remain on the air so we
would appreciate it if you would support
them as well one of those sponsors all
very important these days is quip you
know under the current circumstances
basic habits like oral hygiene can
sometimes go by the wayside you know you
don't necessarily go to the drugstore
you don't replace the things you got to
replace that's exactly what you need to
get a great toothbrush and stick to your
healthy habits good health starts with
good habits simple as that we talked
about that principle on the show all the
time you got to get into good habits
quit makes it easy by delivering all the
oral care essentials that you need to
brush and floss better the quip electric
toothbrush has timed sonic vibrations
with 30 second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended 2 minute routine and there's
even a size down version designed for
kids you pair this with quips anti
cavity toothpaste and mint or watermelon
you get all the ingredients that teeth
actually need and none that they don't
equips is just tremendous go right now
to get quip comm slash Michael you will
get your first refill free that is get
quip calm slash michael GE t qu IP
dot-com / mi CH AE el quip the good
habits company so gavin newsom right
covering his political derriere he sent
this letter on March 18th to president
Trump dear mr. president I write to
respectfully request you immediately
deploy the USNS mercy hospital ship to
be stationed in LA through September to
help decompress our current health care
system as you know California has been
disproportionately impacted by
repatriation efforts we projected
roughly 56 percent of our population 25
point 5 million people
we'll be infected with the virus over an
eight week period none of his
predictions came true certainly not by
the official count the hospital system
was not overwhelmed California is
actually doing relatively quite well so
he was wrong he was wrong and as it
becomes clear that he's wrong he's
doubling down you see this in Chicago -
Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot saying that
she's gonna throw people in jail if they
don't stay in their dank apartments now
I've directed superintendent Brown to
order all police districts to give
special attention to these parties and
this is how it's gonna be we will shut
you down
we will cite you and if we need to we
will arrest you and we will take you to
jail period there should be nothing
unambiguous about that don't make us
treat you like a criminal but if you act
like a criminal and you violate the law
and you refuse to do what is necessary
to save lives in the city in the middle
of a pandemic we will take you to jail
period so this kind of talk is very
offensive to an American we don't like
to hear our politicians talk to us like
this pretty disgraceful not in keeping
with our national tradition of respect
for our citizens free government
self-government right and yet she's kind
of got a point
I mean she's dead wrong and how she
talks and what she does and pretty much
everything cuz she's a very crooked
Chicago politician but she does have a
point here it gets to something that we
were talking about last week in our
description of freedom and what it means
to be free and how we learn to be free
there will be order okay the government
will impose order on us or we will
impose order on ourselves and in the
early tradition of the United States we
had a rigorous system of self-government
very local government strong families
strong liberal arts the liberal arts
being the way that we make sense of our
freedom and earn our freedom and
discipline ourselves very religious john
adams said this remember he said our
constitution is built for a moral and
religious people it is unfit to the
governance of other kinds of people we
have a free government but it
you're gonna have a free government
doesn't mean just do what you want free
government means you control yourselves
so that we don't have to impose it on
you and increasingly particularly over
the last 50 or 60 years there has been a
social movement in this country the left
that has sought to take away those
controls so most noticeably you see this
in the realm of sex we saw it at the
beginning with free love it's moved on
to you do you it's going on to the moral
standard of if it feels good do it that
now there is basically no limit to our
sexual expression we should indulge at
any sexual desire that we have basically
at any time you saw then the breakdown
of marriage which is the fundamental
building block of society you saw the
rise of no-fault divorce you saw the
rise of slightly strange a little bit
kooky living situations you saw a social
breakdown at that level then this rises
up to the community level communities
don't remain quite as strong as as you
have the sort of cult of the atomized
individual and pursuing one's own
individual self-interest at the expense
of any kind of public interest these
localities start to break down people
move away first of all from them they
don't participate in their own civic
civil society you see the voluntary
associations that political observers
like Alexis de Tocqueville observed in
America you know the Lions Club the PTA
that kind of thing those start to break
down as well ultimately at the end of
this I'm skipping a lot of steps but you
know in the interest of time you get to
what Barack Obama in 2012 described as
the life of Julia and this this was so
honest of the left talking about their
their platform that they actually
scrubbed it from the internet because it
was very spooky and the life of Julia
was this description cradle to grave of
this woman's life where she has no
meaningful relationship with anybody but
the federal government no husband no
local community no nothing nothing no
family just the government even when she
chooses to have a child she doesn't get
fall in love get married you know have a
big baptism have a party yet no none of
that she chooses to have a child and
then the government takes care of that
child for her and that's that's it as we
pursue merely our own individual desires
then the power of the government grows
and they control us now what's funny is
Lori Lightfoot here this leftist
politician she's sort of complaining
about this she's pretending she's upset
the left has been hoping for this for 60
years at least okay and it's up to us to
fight back against that if we want to
not be talked to by our politicians like
that if we want to have a little dignity
and respect and freedom in this country
we need to govern our own desires
now what Lori Lightfoot is saying is if
you go out and you know don't listen
every word we're saying then you're not
behaving you're not controlling yourself
that's not true we don't need to control
ourselves in the way the politicians
want us to control ourselves certainly
not but we do need to be able to control
ourselves our desires our actions our
behaviors so that not only will the
politicians not talk to us that way
because they have such respect for us
there's such good people out of the
kindness of their heart because they
won't be allowed to because some hack
tube it would be totalitarians
wouldn't dare speak that way to a free
people now speaking of two-bit tin pot
would be world leaders we will get to
Joe Biden he had a mostly disastrous but
it still probably won't matter interview
on MSNBC to address the sexual assault
allegations we'll get to that in a
second first got to thank our friends
over at LifeLock LifeLock is very
important these days you've got to be
prepared you know people who were
prepared for every eventuality right and
you're not one of those people but you'd
like to be breeches seem like they're
happening more and more these days and
with your breached information like your
name social security number and more
criminals can commit identity theft and
that's why life lock sees more threats
like someone taking out a payday loan in
your name alerts you to possible
suspicious activity and if you end up
having an identity theft issue you will
be talking to your dedicated identity
restoration specialist just a phone call
away no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions and
all businesses but with breaches on the
rise doesn't it make sense to be
prepared you're doing a lot more online
these days make sure you're prepared
join LifeLock and save up to 25% of your
first year go to LifeLock dot-com slash
Knolls that is a Lifeloc comm slash
Knowles Canada wles
and my gift to you you will save 25% you
just have to go to LifeLock dot-com /
Knowles can interview le s Joe Biden
finally addresses the sexual assault
allegations from Tara Reid mainstream
media been doing a good job of covering
up for him and not asking questions
finally he goes on Morning Joe he talks
to Micah Brzezinski and he makes the
strongest defense I've heard yet of why
we should not pin these allegations on
him I don't remember any type of
complaint she may have made it was 27
years ago and I don't remember nor does
anyone else that I'm aware of and the
fact is that I don't remember I don't
remember any complaint ever having been
made the fact is I don't remember this
is by far Joe Biden's best defense the
one thing I believe from Joe Biden is
that he doesn't remember absolutely
neighborhood doesn't remember his own
name he doesn't remember where he is at
all so he makes this argument which we
would expect and it was by far the
highlight of the interview further down
in the interview he starts to break
apart he you know that Joe Biden is not
great with his words he's always putting
his foot in his mouth he lets out a
little bit too much so mica asks him
okay you don't remember this do you know
if there is a record of this woman
filing a complaint are you absolutely
certain that there is no record that she
filed a complaint that's a great
opportunity where if there is no
complaint Joe Biden to come out and say
yes there is no complaint take that one
to the bank this is BS we're moving on
but he can't say that because it seems
very likely that there is a complaint
and so Joe Biden gives us this word
salad non-answer of an answer as we this
is a very I'm sorry guys please know
much as we await for the records from
the National Archives are you absolutely
certain are you absolutely positive
there is no record of any complaint by
Tara Reid against you I am absolutely
positive
no one that I'm aware of ever has been
made aware of any complaint a formal
complaint made by or complaint by Tara
Reid against me at the time this
allegedly happened 27 years ago or until
the I announced for pret well it was
guess was in April or May of this year
I'm AB let me see if I get this right
I'm absolutely certain that I'm certain
and that there's no record of a
complaint that of anyone that I talked
to having a record or or a complaint or
a complaint of anyone from the time and
the ever or until May or until April no
I I think I'm pretty no absolutely no
aware those worth I guess every word
that Joe Biden used to made sense when
you put them together they didn't mean
anything and they didn't they didn't
mean anything because he can't be
certain that there isn't a complaint and
very likely he thinks that there is a
complaint so okay so far basically so
good what else is he gonna say he's
gonna use mealy-mouthed politician
language I don't remember this well I
there's there's probably not a chance
that maybe there is then Joe Biden goes
too far and we kind of move actually
past the Tara Reid sexual assault stuff
into the broader problem of Joe Biden's
public life which is that he's held
virtually every position on virtually
every issue he doesn't really believe
anything he's corrupt there's a lot of
evidence of his own corruption and so to
begin Mika says why can't we just search
these records your records are at the
University of Delaware let's just open
them up and give him a search he goes we
can't search those records because those
records contain many of my speeches and
publicly held positions from over the
years and it would be unfair for those
speeches and positions to be re-released
publicly while I'm running for office
he's basically saying it would be very
unfair for people to know what I've
thought and done for my whole career
because then nobody would vote for me
okay please go ahead the first is about
to the University of Delaware records do
you agree with the reporting
that those records were supposed to be
revealed to the public and then they
were resealed for a longer period of
time until after you leave quote public
life and if you agree with that if
that's what happened why did that happen
because look the fact is that there's a
lot of things that of speeches I've made
positions I've taken interviews that
that I did overseas with people all of
those things relating to my job and the
idea that they would all be made public
in the fact while I was running for
public office they could be really taken
out of context the papers are position
papers they are documents that existent
and and that that when I for example
when I go when I met with Putin or when
I met with whomever and all of that to
be fodder in a campaign at this time and
I don't know of anybody who's done
anything like that and so the National
Archives is the only place there would
be anything having to do with personnel
records there are no personnel records
in the Biden papers at the University
stop talking quit while you're ahead
initially says look I don't have any
there's no personnel records in here so
there's no reason to open these up I
don't have any recollection of the
complaint no one else does either also
we can't open them up because it's got
all my positions that I've held over the
years and we don't want people to know
about my positions also there are
conversations I've had with Vladimir
Putin we definitely don't want people to
hear that what dude now all you've done
is convince me from the beginning of
that clip to the end that we definitely
need to reopen those records for way
more than the Tara Reid stuff I don't
really care that much about the Tara
Reid stuff I mean it's a good attack on
Joe Biden because of the absolute rank
hypocrisy of the me2 movement and
feminists which we'll get to in a moment
because Lisa bloom the famous feminist
lawyer has proved this perfectly but
it's not really about the Tara Reid
stuff because the Joe Biden does have a
point it's been 27 years and it's
strange that these things are just
coming up now
should they be investigated yeah sure I
suppose so they're far more credible
than the Brett Kavanaugh allegations I
have a far more sympathetic view of the
accuser in this case than any of the
FEMEN
- so surely we should at least take it
seriously but it's not just the Tara
Reid stuff it's his whole career and he
says no we can't look at that he's
actually kind of agreeing with me saying
yeah if we're not that worried about the
allegation we're worried about my whole
career he goes on and unbelievable you
got to give it to Joe Biden he somehow
makes a bad defense even worse when he
says forget even about my public papers
what about all the contacts I've had
with foreign governments what about my
conversations with Barack Obama that I
had about those foreign governments why
not do it for both sets of Records
because the material in the University
of Delaware has no personnel files that
it has but it does have a lot of
confidential conversations that I had
with the president about a particular
issue that I had with the heads of state
of other places that that would not be
something that would be revealed while I
was in public office or while I was
seeking public office you had a lot of
conversations with President men
President Barack Obama about a
particular issue and on this issue you
also had conversations with heads of
state what might that particular issue
be with that particular issue be the
actual biggest scandal of your recent
campaign the issue that while you were
vice president running relations with
the Ukraine you insisted that the
prosecutor who was investigating your
crooked son get fired in exchange for
aid from the United States would it
would it be that on this issue of
Ukraine and Hunter Biden and burries m'a
that that clip where you said we're
gonna withhold the funding if you don't
fire this guy I'll call Barack Obama
right now would it be you know that
clippers kind of floating around would
that be the issue maybe is that the
issue that you don't want to come up I
don't know I'm just raising questions I
haven't seen the files but it sure as
hell seems to me that we should Biden
taking a bad particular situation which
is this increasingly credible
allegation against him although we don't
know that it is actually credible right
don't forget it still took decades for
this thing to come out story has changed
a little bit far more credible than
Christine Blasi forward but let's not
get ahead of ourselves here right he's
taking this bad problem for his campaign
and turning it into a much broader
problem that reflects on his own
corruption and his own political
weaknesses and then he gets to the worst
clip the most Awkward clip of the entire
interview we'll get to that in one
second and we'll get to president
Trump's wild incredible brilliant
response to Joe Biden's interview but
first time is running out when you
become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member you know what you get
you gonna left us your Stumbler you know
that right what if I told you that you
get two leftist ears Tumblr's two
magnificent tumblers and this deal ends
tomorrow deals like this don't come
around very often I think we've only
done this this time I think it's the
first time we've ever done it so right
now take advantage of it and existing
members I know you may feel a little bit
of envy don't worry we have a special
offer coming up just for you very
important thing to get these two
tumblers because as the entire modern
feminist movement collapses which it did
yesterday you're gonna need the tumblers
to collect all of the tears go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back
okay so I've got to warn you when you
listen to Joe Biden's response on this
there's gonna be a pause your audio has
not gone out the podcast has not stopped
it's just that awkward what's funny
about this is that it's actually Joe
Biden's best defense but he couldn't
give it right
classic Joe Biden move so Mika asks if
there's nothing there in the records why
not do a search I'm just talking about
her name not anybody else in those
records a search for that nothing
classified to the President or anybody
else I'm just asking why not do a search
for Tara Reid's name in the University
of Delaware records look I mean who does
that search the University of Delaware
perhaps you set up a commission that can
do it I don't know whatever is the
fairest way to create the most
transparency well this is look mica she
said she filed a report she has her
employment records still she said she
filed a report with the only office that
wouldn't have a report in the United
States Senate at the time if the report
was ever filed it was filed there period
he finally got around to it it's their
period it's all over but not before that
long awkward pause this is Joe Biden's
best defense as to why he doesn't want
to open up his sealed records at the
University of Delaware and that defense
is who's going to do the search we're in
the midst of a presidential campaign
nobody could possibly be without some
kind of interest here without some kind
of bias so we just can't do it is nobody
would have the objectivity to do it if
the Biden campaign did the search no one
would believe it if the University of
Delaware did the search it might leak
still perhaps no one would believe it if
some other political operatives are
brought in it would be too unreliable
and too dangerous and other candidates
actually wouldn't do it but Joe Biden
can't get this out there so Joe Biden
just destroys himself as always as he
always does just his campaign gets worse
and worse and worse all on his own
Nicole Wallace mainstream media reporter
MSNBC decides that it's not Joe Biden's
own fault it's not Mika Brzezinski zone
fault it's not Tara Reid's fault you're
not technically allowed to blame Tara
Reid even though that's what the
Democrats are trying to do she's saying
that this whole ask this whole aspect of
the attack on Joe Biden is a smear
campaign being run by Republicans I
think that this is a year without
campaigns without a campaign trail
without a campaign press corps and the
silver lining if you will is that voters
are gonna have to watch that interview
this morning and and make their own
judgments about there are no more
arbiters there are no more pooh-bahs in
either party let me just say this to
having once been a part of the
Republican Party the right isn't running
an intellectually honest operation to
get to the bottom of whether Tara Reid
was victimized the right is running a
smear campaign against Joe Biden
it's a smear campaign being run by the
right it's being run by the right really
I thought it was being run by Tara Reid
who is a Democrat who isn't just a
Democrat she's a democratic staffer who
worked for Joe Biden that's what it is
and by the way Republicans have been
actually pretty less a fair about this
whole thing we haven't totally embraced
the Tara Reid stuff we're pointing out
the hypocrisy of how Kavanaugh was
treated versus how Biden's being treated
by the media but we're not totally
embracing it actually here's my evidence
president Trump is sort of defending Joe
Biden is a brilliant totally unexpected
but a brilliant move president Trump was
on Dan bungee knows podcast just a
couple days ago and he was asked about
the Tara Reid allegations and you ask
yourself how's Trump gonna respond is he
gonna go hard after Joe and call him a
creepy sexual assailant is he going to
stay out of the fray or this is the
bizarre
option is he going to defend Joe Biden
and actually defending Joe Biden was
politically the smartest move I've been
falsely accused by people that I've
never even seen I've never even seen
many of these people and some of them I
met them zero interest okay like zero
and all of a sudden you become a wealthy
guy you're a famous guy then you become
president and people just people that
you've never seen that you've never
heard of make charges so you know I
guess in a way you could say I'm I'm
sticking up for him but the mother was
very compelling certainly and the
girlfriend or the friends were very
compelling and certainly far more
compelling than anything they had with
respect to Brett Kavanaugh this is one
of the most high-quality human beings
what they did to that family and that
man is a disgrace so Scott Adams the
Dilbert guy gave some good analysis of
this a few other people have as well but
Scott's is worth checking out Trump is
in a very tough spot here right because
if Trump goes after Joe based on these
allegations as some creepy sexual
assailant well look Donald Trump has
been a playboy for much of his career
and so you can always dredge up a bunch
of people who were calling him some kind
of sexual asylum none with the
credibility of Tara Reid against Joe
Biden right you always hear this from
the left they say there's 20 accusations
of sexual misconduct against Trump 25 50
million accusations of sexual misconduct
the way that you know that there aren't
really 20 serious allegations of sexual
misconduct against Trump is if any of
them were really credible the mainstream
media would not have shut up about it
for the last four years but they don't
have any actual credible allegations
against Trump
so they trot out a porn star that he had
a completely consensual relationship
with remember stormy Daniels they used
that for like a year or two years if
they had someone who actually said that
guy raped me that guy assaulted me then
we would know her name right but you
never hear the names just you're all
it's 20 it's 25 women so Trump still
knows that he's not going to be treated
fairly in the media and so he takes this
really reasonable position which is look
we don't know if these claims
famous people famous men do get targeted
with false allegations this has happened
a lot we don't know if the allegations
are true or not against Joe the only
thing we know is that the left and the
media are being completely hypocritical
here this is the same argument this is
the by far the best argument that
conservatives could possibly make and it
leaves the left no wiggle room right
they've tried to put us in an impossible
position we turn it around and put them
in that position Lisa bloom Gloria
Allred's daughter Lisa bloom one of the
most famous feminist lawyers in the
country took this she was in this
impossible position and she took it to
its logical conclusion I I think that
this tweet from Lisa bloom will be cited
by sociologists as the precise moment
that feminism died she tweets out
unbelievable I believe you Tara Reid you
have people who remember you told them
about this decades ago we know he is
handsy you're not asking for money
you've obviously struggled mightily with
this I still have to fight Trump so I
still support Joe but I believe you and
I'm sorry that is a stunning statement
from the feminist left and it confirms
everything we have said about them from
the beginning which is this is not about
supporting women this is not about the
objective pursuit of truth this is not
about fighting the oppressors and
helping the oppressed or whatever
language they use this is a been
attacking conservatives this is about
attacking our culture which
conservatives obviously want to conserve
the me2 movement has gone from believe
all women in 2016 to now in 2020 believe
all women and elect their rapists that's
what she's saying she's saying I believe
that Joe Biden is a sexual asal --nt I
believe it I believe everything you're
claiming is true and I'm sorry but I'm
definitely still going to vote for him
at least Lisa bloom is honest she's
catching a lot of flack for this because
what she's saying is indefensible but
the whole feminist left is indefensible
no they just lie and they try to be
hypocrites at least at least what Lisa
bloom is doing is admitting what this is
ahead of the times up you know the times
up me too organization kind of times up
is defending Biden too disbelieving Reed
same thing with Debra Messing the famous
leftist actress same thing with Alyssa
Milano some people are shocked by the
double standard I am NOT okay this was
never about principles not the me2
movement not feminism not any of the
leftist social movements that we've seen
over the last hundred years not any part
of leftism it's not about principles or
standards it's about you it's about
tearing you down it's about taking away
your culture taking away your country
taking away your traditions and your
rituals or rich rituals or your rituals
your dialects that might pronounce
rituals as rituals you everything that
you cherish that you want to conserve
it's about tearing that down it's about
deconstruction right these are the kind
of words that you hear all the time from
the left deconstruction social
constructs and deconstruction right they
want to rip it down they don't like you
they don't like your culture they don't
like your traditions they don't like
your history they don't like your
civilization they want to tear it down
if feminism will tear it down they'll
use feminism if the hijab will tear it
down they'll use the hijab right they'll
use kind of Islamic identity politics
feminism and the hijab don't really go
together doesn't matter they'll use
whichever ones convenient if gay
identity politics will tear it down
they'll use that if transgender identity
politics will tear it down which totally
undermined gay identity politics all
right the whole idea of homosexual
identity politics is were born this way
there is such a thing as biological sex
we're attracted to people of the same
sex transgenderism says none of that's
true there is no such thing as sex
anyway we can be men can be women women
can be men
it's transphobic if you're not attracted
to the people that I want you to be
attracted to doesn't matter they'll use
either one and we're perpetually
shocked that people like Linda Sarsour
right Islamists will hold hands with
Gloria Steinem leftist secular feminists
at the Women's March we say these two
people don't have a lot in common but
yet they hold hands at the Women's March
they do have something in common they
have a common enemy and that's you and
your culture and your civilization we're
shocked that they believe Christine
Blasi forward but not Tara Reid why it's
not about any principle okay it's just
about tearing down the culture it is
purely a politics of opposition this is
not even a conflict of visions for the
culture it's about culture and it's
about anti culture and that's it and we
should be open eyed to it and stop being
these naive little children who are
perpetually shocked and we say yeah but
look at the hypocrisy they don't care
about the hypocrisy point out the
hypocrisy because it's important to win
over conservatives and moderates and
independence the left doesn't care it
was never about principles it was always
about you speaking of people who are
misunderstanding the political moment
former president george w bush issued a
whole message about how terrible the
viruses and it's a feel-good message you
know we've got to be nice to everybody
and this is a tough time but we'll get
through it
okay that's fine most of its
unobjectionable then he gets to his
political advice in this moment and this
political advice was dead wrong let's
remember that the suffering we
experienced as a nation does not fall
evenly in the days to come it will be
especially important to care in
practical ways for the elderly the ill
and the of
finally let us remember how small our
differences are in the face of this
shared threat in the final analysis we
are not partisan combatants we're human
beings equally vulnerable and equally
wonderful in the sight of God we rise or
fall together and we are determined to
rise god bless you all
okay basically an unobjectionable
message right except for the political
advice he seems to be giving here he's
saying by the final count were not just
political opponents yeah that's true
ultimately my ultimate identity is not
as a political opponent of somebody else
but in this political moment that is an
important aspect of our character
because the left doesn't forget that
they have a political agenda but very
often conservatives do forget that we
have a political agenda the left has
been telling us for 50 years the
personal is the political everything is
the political and some conservatives
unfortunately like former President Bush
are trying to pretend that that is not
the case and a lot of the failings on
the right during the Bush era I think
are attributable to this problem this is
a political moment right now the
authoritarian hack politicians on the
Left are using the coronavirus as an
opportunity to punish their political
opponents to wield arbitrary political
power without any reasoning left
whatsoever and to cover their own
political derrieres
with even more punitive measures okay
that is political and it is important
for us as free citizens of this republic
to use our political mechanisms at our
disposal to push back against that this
is political it'd be really nice if we
could just kumbaya all the time that is
not how this is working at this moment
and conservatives who think that that is
the way forward I think are woefully
misguided before we go I've got to talk
about a conservative who was not ever
woefully misguided a conservative who is
a real real role model for people today
and she's been in many ways written out
of history and now the left is trying to
rewrite her history when they put her
back into history that person is Phyllis
Schlafly Phyllis Schlafly I had the
great privilege of attending a dinner
with her shortly before she died and so
this was toward the end of her life and
she gave a rousing lucid brilliant
political speech there as she always did
Phyllis Schlafly
very very prominent in the 1970s
fighting against the so-called Equal
Rights Amendment the Equal Rights
Amendment was this leftist nonsense that
tried to redefine sex and gender to say
that there is no difference whatsoever
between sex and what the equal right
there's actually a new push right now to
to ratify the Equal Rights Amendment
what it would do is in in the long run
at the extreme abolish things like
same-sex schools because men and women
wouldn't be treated perfectly equally it
would abolish same-sex restrooms which
is already happening people mocked
Phyllis Schlafly said she was lying when
she said that that would come to pass
it's already happening even without the
ER a said that women would be drafted
there's a big push again to do that
right now basically everything this
woman predicted about politics has come
true even though she did a great job
slowing it down by stopping the
Orwellian Equal Rights Amendment and so
what one of those brilliant women that
has ever existed in American politics
there's a new show which I'm watching
right now it's generally a pretty good
show but at crucial moments they try to
rewrite the history I'll show you
exactly how they do it here's a clip
Phyllis Schlafly is debating some
feminist from the ACLU and this is a
real debate these events are you know
every scene in the show is based on real
events but then it gets interpreted
loosely here is how the TV show portrays
this debate going down I mean the courts
would decide as they did with a recent
Washington DC case where three children
were given to the father and the mother
had to pay child support it was they say
that was an advance for women but then
the larger issue is that the ER a erodes
the institution of marriage is not a
static divorce the case well I'd have to
look it up but the point you don't know
the name of the case well there's so
many cases we don't have time to cite
the case I just named this one case the
point is if everything must be equal in
the logical extension of the ER a is
that we would have a gender-neutral
system I scared the women of America
into believing something that is not
based in reality but when you argue an
actual point in the real world in a
court of law you need to cite a case to
support your arguments of cite the case
well I think it was fully rested Langham
or Lancaster something like that no
there is no such case oh yes there is
but you see you just wake up I'm not a
lawyer no oh wow what a this finish lo
she looks to her husband should know the
answer she is so dumb and to end
deceptive because she's making up these
cases right except here's the problem
that never happened that never ever
happened didn't happen in that debate
that's a real debate we can go back and
watch the tape you can find the tape the
the Phyllis Schlafly Eagles actually the
organization to preserve her legacy just
did a great video on this comparing
shot-by-shot throughout much of this
show all of the ways that they
completely lie about history so I go
over check that out on the Phyllis
Schlafly Eagles page this moment did not
happen ever
she Phyllis Schlafly never invented a
case in this debate she never invented a
case in any political debate and
actually what happened in real life
during the debate is that moment that
Phyllis got all flustered because the
feminists got her on the ropes in
reality it was the exact opposite it was
this feminist who Phyllis was debating
who was contrary to the TV show not
confident not particularly intelligent
not particularly good on camera it was
she who made an obviously false claim
and who got called out for it and who
couldn't answer it here's the reality
many lending institutions count a
woman's income only for half of what it
is if she is married and between the
ages of 20 and 44 and cannot show that
she has been sterilized okay that that
goes for banks that goes for department
stores are you saying that they inquire
if women are sterilized absolutely any
place that does that there's any place
it does
they do just give me the name of one
Institute I'd like to I'd like to
continue as a bank in Queens I'm not
going to name it oh you're not I don't
think I've never heard of one yeah but
this wouldn't be a plug if there is any
institution in this country that it then
becomes a major news event what we want
to know in that case I can guarantee you
will be a front-page story on even then
let me let me let me just lay it out I
mean this is the chance to that place oh
it's exactly the opposite it's even
worse they actually this woman did even
worse in the moment than they're
pretending that Phyllis Schlafly did
because she just made up this policy and
it made up anxious so I'm not gonna say
the name why not you're fighting for
women's rights why don't you name them
isn't that the whole point of your
movement well no I'm not I don't wanna
know I'm not gonna name my boyfriend he
lives in Canada no I don't think uh uh
no and I don't think so this is how they
do it this is what the left does this is
what Hollywood does because no one most
people don't remember Phyllis Schlafly
anyway because she's been written out of
the history books but now what people
are going to remember is this TV show
that's what they're going to remember or
they're going to how are they gonna
remember JFK they're gonna remember
Oliver Stone's movie is anti historical
movie this is what the left does we
talked about on a couple episodes ago we
talked about how all news is fake now
all history is fake by that I mean some
of its true but you really have to look
with a critical eye at all of these
things because it's about you okay it's
not about principle it's not about
telling the truth it's not about the
objective pursuit of what really
happened it's about tearing down a very
particular culture of a particular
country or a particular civilization and
they will do that by any means necessary
and we need to be on guard because that
is being done in clear ways through
political attacks that we see all the
time through policies that that
governors are forcing on us every day
and it's being done in subtle ways like
the rewriting of news and the rewriting
of history but don't look for a
principle just look for who the intended
victim is but look through the intended
enemy is that person I'm sorry to say is
you all right that's our show I'm
Michael Knowles's the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Cleveland
[Music]